that baby's frozen up now
pew
I think what I need to do now is uh
build a fire
trying to all this thing out and
hopefully I can get back to work
first truck is probably one of the best
natural fire stars there is out here
even if this is wet it'll burn really
quick as you spend more and more time
out here you begin to look at things in
a very different way I look at trees it
what can I use off of them if you lay a
couple of green logs down you can keep
the fire going quite a long time living
out here is not just how to do things if
you don't have the right philosophy of
life out here it's a struggle you have
to want to live this way
look at that Turner now yeah I just
gotta keep it out of the snow now all
nice some warmer it'll just ice up again
this stuff gets in there and it's all
iced up and creates a lot of friction
and all the oil that's nubret aiding the
bar gets placed up well that feels good
god only made one mistake when he
designed man and that was he needed to
have bigger veins in the thumb what are
you guys doing here did you bring lunch
huh put your work in here chainsaw froze
up oh man thanks for bringing my parka I
get cold pretty quick since I stopped
besides that trouble oh it's slower
that's really thick back there
it's it's gonna be a lot of work I still
got quite a bit to do be careful because
you know how I get with a chainsaw oh
I'm gonna give you a wide berth
Kate's out here with me throwing the cut
stuff out and making a lot more progress
with her here if I'm lucky a few more
hours if I'm not another day or so cut
and it's hard to say I'm gonna be glad
when this trails in because I'll be able
to use this for a long time so even
though this is a lot of work this is
going to be a big payoff in the long run
for us I just got to keep working